Trascrizione: Adriana Centrone
Revisore: Piero Cavallo
“Un mondo per noi.”
Ho ripetuto più volte nella
mia testa questa frase.
“Un mondo per noi.”
Come possiamo fare quindi
del bene alle persone?
Molto spesso commettiamo azioni che hanno
un risvolto solo sulla propria vita,
non su quella delle persone
che abbiamo di fronte a noi.
Però il mondo è per noi,
è un mondo in cui noi tutti conviviamo.
Sono un ragazzo giovane,
non credo di avere superpoteri
o qualità che mi rendono
migliore di altri,
però so di avere
una forza di volontà abbastanza forte.
Il mio desiderio è quello
di poter aiutare le persone.
Oggi vi porto la mia idea.
Non vi prometto che sarà l’idea
più bella che ascolterete,
la più interessante
o che vi appassiona di più.
Però potrebbe avere
qualche risvolto positivo, secondo me.
La mia idea parte dalla mia passione
che è la musica.
Immagino che qui dentro,
chiunque sia stato toccato dalla musica
una volta nella vita.
chi ascolta un ritornello di una canzone
e la ripete tutto il giorno,
o chi semplicemente si sente protagonista
di una canzone che ha ascoltato
perché sembra che il testo sia fatto
a pennello su di noi.
Sono appassionato di musica
e mi ritengo fortunato.
Mi ritengo fortunato perché,
nella mia scuola,
scuola, quindi un ambiente di istruzione,
un ambiente didattico,
un ambiente che ci dicono
che ci prepara per il mondo esterno,
per la vera realtà.
Ci sono laboratori musicali,
laboratori che aiutano persone come me,
appassionati di musica a esprimermi,
che è una cosa fondamentale
per noi giovani oggigiorno, no?
Riusciamo a venirci incontro,
collaboriamo.
Con il nostro lavoro, poi,
dopo lo portiamo a fine anno
in spettacoli, progetti, che lo facciamo
nei teatri ma anche in altre zone.
Portiamo la nostra passione ovunque.
Facciamo degli scambi, scambi
con scuole provenienti da altri paesi,
studenti che hanno lingua,
età o cultura diversa dalla nostra.
Creiamo questi legami
che sono duraturi nel tempo.
Mi sento fortunato per questo.
La mia concezione di scuola si è ampliata.
Non è più quella dove un ragazzo,
una ragazza sta tutto il giorno sul banco
a guardare il libro, a studiare,
a fare il proprio compito.
Ovviamente,
è un ambiente scolastico, certo,
però è un ambiente anche
dove noi possiamo crescere,
coltivare le nostre passioni,
esprimere la nostra potenzialità.
Mi chiedo se ci sono altre scuole così.
Il mio desiderio è quello
di aiutare le persone
e sfruttare l’aiuto
della scuola per questo.
Mi emoziona pensare come qualcosa
come la musica,
apparentemente banale come la musica,
possa portare la felicità
a persone che si svegliano la mattina
e non hanno il problema
di cosa faranno a lavoro
o cosa possono comprarsi,
ma hanno il pensiero della salute.
La salute non si può comprare,
lo sappiamo tutti.
Persone che ritengono il tempo
la maggiore fonte di ricchezza
che possano desiderare.
Il mio desiderio è questo,
portare della felicità queste persone qui.
Allora ho pensato a qualcosa
che potesse conciliare tutto questo
e subito in testa ho detto la parola
“musicoterapia”.
La musicoterapia è una terapia
basata sull’utilizzo della musica.
Facile.
È utilizzata in vari ambiti, che sia
quello educativo, terapeutico o curativo.
Basti pensare che noi iniziamo
a sentire i primi suoni
prima che nasciamo,
nella vita intrauterina.
Vuol dire nella pancia della mamma.
Sentiamo il suo battito cardiaco,
sentiamo il suo respiro.
Ogni giorno
siamo condizionati dalla musica.
Basta pensare come una canzone
riesce a cambiarci l’umore.
O come il nostro stato d’animo
influenza la canzone che ascoltiamo.
La musicoterapia è utilizzata oggigiorno
per le terapie psichiatriche.
Ha diversi effetti positivi,
è stato dimostrato.
Per esempio, aiuta a calmare quei sintomi
tipici delle persone
che soffrono di schizofrenia.
O anche l’ascoltare musica ci produce...
ci fa produrre particolari endorfine
che aiutano a distrarci,
a calmarci, a rilassarci.
Tipo, per esempio, a me servirebbe
un po’ di musica in questo momento.
Ok.
(Applauso)
Ha diversi aspetti positivi.
Agisce sul fisico.
Ci sono atleti che ascoltano musica
prima di partecipare a una gara.
Si pensa che possa incrementare
la prestazione.
Si può utilizzare anche
nella riabilitazione
e ha effetti enormemente positivi
per le persone che hanno difficoltà
a comunicare, nell’interagire socialmente.
Infatti è utilizzato come supporto
per persone affette da autismo,
per esempio.
Non sono musicoterapeuta.
Non è questo il mio ruolo.
Non voglio dilungarmi troppo
perché non sono qui per questo.
Sicuramente ci sono tanti effetti positivi
che la musica può dare a noi
e l’abbiamo capito
e qualcun altro
potrebbe spiegarcelo ancora.
Io sono qui per farvi vedere una visione
un po’ più concreta della cosa.
Il mio desiderio è quello di creare
un percorso curricolare nelle scuole.
Per esempio, come nella mia.
Però qualcosa di più in grande,
dei veri corsi,
sostenuti dalla scuola,
per studenti come me,
che sono tantissimi,
che vogliono portare del bene,
entrare in un’altra dimensione,
realtà che sembrano tanto distanti da noi,
ma che in realtà non lo sono per niente.
Per esempio, un ospedale
o un centro di assistenza
e portare la felicità,
portare il sorriso a chi non sorride
da tanto tempo.
Fare dei corsi.
Le ore sono di alternanza,
ovviamente sono facoltativi.
Chi vuole partecipare
è libero di farlo, chi no, no.
Sarebbero sostenuti
da persone qualificate,
persone che sono sia esperti in musica
sia in psicologia.
Secondo me, sarebbe davvero istruttivo,
avrebbe un impatto devastante sul ragazzo,
perché immaginiamo avere
un’esperienza del genere.
È questo che molte volte
ci limita a scuola, no?
Pensare che studiamo delle cose
che però non applicheremo mai nella vita.
“Cosa studio questo?
Tanto non mi servirà mai.”
E invece, pensare che quello
che studiamo a scuola
riusciamo a renderlo nel pratico,
nella vita vera.
Portare della felicità.
Questo sarebbe il mio obiettivo.
Ora, non so se la mia idea
vi possa piacere,
se è arrivata a tutti allo stesso modo
o la trovate originale.
Spero che in questa stanza, però,
che tra le persone
che mi vedano, mi ascoltano,
ci sia qualcuno interessato ad aiutarmi.
Penso che sia una bella idea,
che possiamo portare del bene
perché ci vuole davvero poco per farlo.
Sarebbe davvero l’esempio
di come sia facile fare azioni per altri,
non per noi,
non per un proprio tornaconto.
Non ci guadagniamo noi niente.
Semplicemente portare del bene
per il piacere di fare del bene,
perché alcune persone se lo meritano.
Secondo me, solo così, piano piano,
riusciamo ad arrivare
a quello che vi ho detto all’inizio:
a un mondo migliore,
un mondo per noi.
(Applauso)
Grazie.